I want to talk about them Chopstick
balloons it was flying over the United
States of America the Chinese Lantern
Festival can we talk about the changes
let's talk about it
she's Korean Alex oh
my bad what sign is that that's North
bro you Gotta Throw the ends up okay all
right so they shot it down yeah right
move or bro move come on come on bro bin
shot that [__] down yeah Ben shot it
down right move or do you think they
left it up there to let everyone know
hey China's a bad guy and then shot it
down while everyone was watching maybe
we were trying to extract as much
information because we knew that [__]
would get damaged on the way down but
what information we got to extract our
own
computers
so you're not gonna slide on China
oh okay let me see your slide
I don't know